niemand wird gegen seinen Willen geimpft
selbst mit der Impfpflicht sei die
Impfung dann ja freiwillig sagt also der
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach das
sind Aussagen die wir hier einmal dem
bild-check unterzogen haben und über
dieses Lauterbach hin und her lauter ja
Nein wollen wir einmal sprechen mit
Sahra Wagenknecht der Linken Politiker
an herzlich willkommen bei bitlife Frau
Wagenknecht
hallo ich grüße sie in der Kommunikation
schon so viel falsch gelaufen in der
alten Regierung Gesundheitsminister Jens
Spahn auch hüh und Hot in vielen Themen
oft wusste man nicht woran man ist wurde
dann hin und wieder hergedreht und dann
kam Karl Lauterbach und alles sollte
besser werden vor allen Dingen weil der
Mann ja so viel mit uns spricht ist es
seitdem besser oder schlechter geworden
naja klar Lauterbach ist ja mit dem
Anspruch eingetreten er würde jetzt
sozusagen die Wissenschaft in die
Politik bringen und ich finde wenn man
sich jetzt die letzten Monate Revue
passieren lässt dann muss man einfach
ganz klar sagen was ja die Politik
gebracht hat ist noch mehr Chaos noch
mehr Willkür noch mehr völlig plötzliche
Entscheidungen also ich meine er ist ja
auch direkt verantwortlich für die
Entscheidung jetzt beim RKI mal eben
über Nacht den genesenen Status auf drei
Monate zu verkürzen Johnson und Johnson
geimpfte nicht mehr als geimpft zu
akzeptieren also das sind ja ständig
Entscheidungen die überhaupt nicht
begründet werden und wo ich mir wirklich
auch große Sorge machen wenn man so
kommuniziert da zerstört man ja auch das
Vertrauen der Menschen immer mehr und
ich finde das wirklich blamabel wie das
jetzt läuft unter Karl Lauterbach heißt
das Frau Wagenknecht Karl Lauterbach hat
seinen Laden nicht im Griff
das weiß ich nicht also ich meine das
RKI ist weisungsgebunden insoweit ist es
schon so dass der Gesundheitsminister
natürlich direkte Verantwortung für
solche Entscheidungen trägt und da er ja
offenbar ein einziges Ziel hat nämlich
dass ich möglichst jeder impfen lässt
egal ob er genesen ist egal wie er sonst
auch sozusagen zur Impfung steht hat das
ja auch eine gewisse Logik aber ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen ich finde es
erschreckend auch wie er immer wieder
versucht den Menschen Panik einzureden
also natürlich wissen wir alle nicht
ganz genau was in den nächsten Wochen
passiert andere europäische Länder haben
sehr hohe Infektionszahlen also da sind
seine zahlen wenn er sagt das werden
dann irgendwie 400.000 sein am Tag das
ist möglich aber wir sehen natürlich
auch in anderen Ländern obwohl die
Zahlen so hoch sind sind die
Intensivstationen relativ wenig belastet
das heißt das ist ja die Spezifik jetzt
von Omegon und ich finde auch da muss
doch ein Gesundheitsminister rational
kommunizieren und nicht immer alles
versuchen den panikmodus so hoch wie
möglich zu halten nur um damit eben
bestimmte Maßnahmen zurechtfertigen
bestimmte Einschränkungen wenn es nach
ihm ginge hätte es ja auch
wahrscheinlich schon sehr viel stärkere
Einschränkungen schon vor Weihnachten
gegeben ich finde dass er da einfach
keinen guten Job macht und würde die
aktuelle Regierung würde Karl Lauterbach
wahrscheinlich sagen er ist ja schön
eine gute auf der Wiese stehen und alles
besser zu wissen das ist halt auch
kompliziert in der corona-krise da
verändert sich die Lage dauernd da muss
man ständig auf andere Virusvarianten
reagieren das ist ja tatsächlich immer
die Argumentation der Regierung wenn man
seine Meinung dann wieder geändert hat
lassen Sie das gelten
naja also natürlich ist es so vor zwei
Jahren Corona war ein neues Virus wir
haben vieles nicht gewusst und auch
innerhalb dieser zwei Jahre gibt es
wahrscheinlich niemanden der sich nicht
geirrt hat der nicht sich auch
korrigieren musste das ist ja auch
völlig normal aber es gibt bei Karl
Lauterbach doch eine ziemlich starke
Kontinuität und das ist dass er immer
das Schlimmste Produkt zitiert hat und
viele Prognosen sind eben nicht
eingetroffen das muss man auch ganz klar
sagen und jetzt ist ja zurzeit sein
Hauptargument auch für die Impfpflicht
ist ja nicht die omegonwelle weil die
wird sowieso in den nächsten Wochen
durchrauschen und wird viele Menschen
infizieren das ist glaube ich gar nicht
vermeidbar aber er sagt jetzt ja im
Herbst werden vielleicht wieder noch
schlimmere Virus Mutanten kommen und
deswegen müssen wir jetzt sozusagen
brauchen wir die Impfpflicht und ich
finde sowas wirklich fahrlässig also ich
denke wenn ich zum Beispiel seriöse
Virologen höre da ist die Meinung
eigentlich eher entspannt die meisten
sagen
Omegon ist jetzt tatsächlich die
Möglichkeit vielleicht diese Pandemie zu
beenden natürlich weiß niemand
hundertprozentig wie dieses Virus noch
mutiert und niemand kann ausschließen
das ist vielleicht auch noch mal andere
Mutanten gibt vielleicht auch welche die
gefährlicher sind aber das ist so so
reine Spekulation und deswegen fand ich
schon bemerkenswert dass zum Beispiel
auch der bekannte Virologe Herr Stöhr ja
gesagt hat Lauterbach irrlichtert also
ich finde das ist ein Begriff der sehr
passend ist zudem wie Lauterbach agiert
und wie er auch seine Positionen auch
teilweise virtuos verändert aber das
Problem ist der ist eben jetzt nicht
einfach nur Talkshow-Gast der ist jetzt
Gesundheitsminister hat eine große
Verantwortung und ich finde er sollte
wirklich in dieser Verantwortung alles
dafür tun dass wir natürlich
versuchen Menschen zu schützen das
Gesundheitssystem vor der Überlastung zu
schützen da wäre einiges zu tun zum
Beispiel endlich den Pflege Bonus
sondern alle Pflegenden auszuzahlen für
bessere arbeitsbeding dafür sorgen also
er hätte ja viel zu tun wenn er das
machen würde wofür er da ist aber er
bleibt in diesem Modus also möglichst
Angst und Schrecken zu verbreiten und
ich finde das ist wirklich nicht das was
wir jetzt brauchen
was brauchen wir denn und vor allem wie
kann es gelingen überhaupt das dem Ende
der Pandemie mal langsam
entgegenzukommen meinen Sie Karl
Lauterbach wird das Gelingen meinen sie
mit seinen Sätzen auch zur Impfpflicht
dass sie zu mehr Freiwilligkeit bei den
Menschen führen wird wird er am Ende
Erfolg haben was prognostizieren sie
das weiß ich nicht ich hoffe schon dass
doch viele Politikerinnen und Politiker
jetzt auch im Bundestag auch andere auch
in den Ländern doch merken es hat sich
ja die Situation verändert also wenn wir
in anderen Ländern sehen dass dort
teilweise die Impfquote nicht höher ist
als Deutschland und trotzdem trotz
Omegon es nicht zu einer Überlastung der
Intensivstation kommt dann muss man sich
doch korrigieren und es bleibt ja auch
dabei selbst wenn die von Lauterbach
beschworenen Mutanten im Herbst wirklich
kommen also neue Virusvarianten keiner
weiß ob der Impfstoff dann auch wirklich
für diese Mutanten wirkt wie stark er
wirkt keiner weiß ob wir dann einen
neuen Impfstoff brauchen das heißt jetzt
die Leute zu zwingen sich mit den
jetzigen Impfstoffen die ja noch auf ein
ganz anderes Virus eigentlich
ausgerichtet sind zu impfen würde für
den Herbst wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal
etwas bringen aber ich finde man kann
doch jetzt auch einmal mal den Leuten
auch erstmal Hoffnung machen also ich
finde es sieht doch zunächst mal relativ
gut aus das Virus ist eigenes harmloser
geworden dass eine sehr gute Nachricht
sollte jetzt nicht zur Fahrlässigkeit
verleiten ganz sicher nicht es gibt
immer noch eine Reihe älterer die nicht
geimpft sind da kann man auch aufklären
da kann man ganz sachlich drüber reden
aber wenn wir die Menschen versuchen
immer wieder zu verängstigen immer
wieder ebenso Panik zu schüren das hat
sich in der ganzen Pandemie nicht
bewährt sondern ich finde gerade
Politiker übrigens auch gute Ärzte
zeichnen sich dadurch aus dass sie
Menschen Mut machen dass sie in Hoffnung
machen und dass sie vor allem wirklich
versuchen rational abzuwägen was ist
jetzt notwendig aber was ist vielleicht
auch nicht mehr angemessen andere
Meinungen können ja anstrengend sein die
bundesinnenministerin hat das offenbar
auch so empfunden und sie hat getwittert
bleibt es doch besser zu Hause wenn ihr
demonstrieren wollt also macht doch im
Moment von eurem Grundrecht bitte keinen
Gebrauch wie finden sie das
ja ich finde sowieso dass wir im Rahmen
dieser Pandemie doch ein sehr
fahrlässigen Umgang mit Grundrechten uns
fast schon daran gewöhnt haben also es
werden Demonstrationen teilweise
verboten präventiv weil man sagt ja da
kommen wahrscheinlich Leute die die
Abstandsregeln nicht einhalten andere
Demonstrationen werden allerdings
erlaubt vielleicht die Abstände auch
nicht so eingehalten werden also es
scheint sehr willkürlich auch in dem
Falle zu sein und ich finde sag mal klar
ein Virus gerade Corona ist gefährlich
für ältere keine Frage aber trotzdem
muss es eine Akzeptanz von Grundrechten
und Meinungsfreiheit und auch
Demonstrationsrecht geben und wir
sollten uns nicht daran gewöhnen dass
Politiker normal finden das außer Kraft
zu setzen also das ist wirklich eine
gefährliche Entwicklung weil man immer
wieder Gründe finden kann warum
bestimmte Dinge vielleicht gerade stören
und dafür haben wir einen Grundgesetz
und wir sind eine Gesellschaft sehr
bewusst die ja nicht so gestaltet ist
wie zum Beispiel die chinesische wo
Menschen auch ja ich habe Vorgaben
kriegen die sie dann einhalten müssen
und ich glaube dass wir hier wirklich
auch mal wieder wertschätzen sollten was
der Wert einer liberalen Gesellschaft
ist und wir müssen sie auch verteidigen
also es ist immer wieder eine Versuchung
dass man liberale Grundsätze einschränkt
weil es vielleicht bequemer für die
Politik ist und das finde ich muss auch
medial sollte es da immer wieder
deutlichen Gegenwind geben und zwar ganz
unabhängig davon ob man jetzt im
Einzelnen eine Demonstration ob man
deren Anliegen teilt oder nicht darum
geht es gar nicht und auch nicht darum
ob man bestimmte Demonstranten
sympathisch findet das ist ja auch sehr
sehr vielfältig was sich zurzeit auf den
Straßen bewegt und die Menschen nehmen
einfach ihr Recht war dazu protestieren
und ich finde dieses Recht haben sie das
sagt linken Politikerin Sarah
Wagenknecht danke Ihnen sehr herzlich
für das Gespräch